hey guys i'm ryan right i'm dance i burn
that [ __ ] off how do you turn it off
I don't know quit the program so today
we're checking out a trailer for Star
Wars The Old Republic Knights of the
Fallen Empire sacrificed trailer like I
keep saying I say this a lot now I'm not
a big gamer but people still want me to
keep checking out these game trailers
and then newcomers get upset when
they're like eh I don't know much yeah
what [ __ ] do you think I bring this guy
by and a lot of people say that there's
no way that I don't see these trailers
and do you know how hard it is to have
III happen and then not watch a single
trailer because you know you're coming
here next it's really upsetting
rebellions I think let's go
yeah okay Dan you're making me
uncomfortable let's do this rated T for
tits incorrect well actually blood and
gore mild language sexual themes
violence
yeah if he's willing to sacrifice
with your birth comes a solemn vow is
the dirt
yeah
- keen an able man
or some version of it or it's like Thor
Loki in the dog
the oath you swear the promises who make
bang
oh wait no they still work together
Wow this is just this is too real
what is it real life look is going to
the losses you suffer
Wow whoa grilling so [ __ ] real
to
something tells me they're under the
impression they're doing the right thing
yes
Oh too
Oh No
I can't believe this
their dad Jessel whatever his face it
he's facing the darkness below
son oh my god I was literally just
talking about doing that to my own kids
uh you know favoritism letting them
fight each other until no not my kids my
kittens I will let the kittens fight
each other to prove which one is worthy
of being mine honestly I think either
way it's either gonna be here it's her
it's gotta be the kitten dude that was
intense
that was really intense when he killed
his brother I was truly shocked I
thought I was gonna be like okay then
he's gonna fight and then it's gonna be
about good brother versus bad brother
but then it wasn't that at all whoa what
did that last him then last like two
seconds and then he got killed and it
was heartbreaking but what a cool speech
and to have it go over that whole
trailer it's like a like a perfect
little short film it looks like such a
different like Star Wars I mean granted
Old Republic is different then most of
the like be I'm well aware that yes just
like Alba can bang combatants everyone
on the battlefield just like completely
like different from what I've ever seen
out of a Star Wars universe looks
[ __ ] no it looks it looks fantastic
man I wish I wish these guys were just
making movies that's why one is really
just to make movies that's that's the
other thing is like like why aren't they
uh I mean it's [ __ ] incredible what
they have going on here I know that was
like great storytelling yeah well I mean
I hope I mean the game's gonna be good
storytelling like traditionally in the
past it's been good storytelling so cuz
the dad was for shattering that you know
he needs the one that's gonna be in the
darkness and he's gonna be alone so he
knew one of them have to take the other
one out some deep [ __ ] is it dick I made
a dick that guy's a dick but I'm telling
you when you do it to your own kittens
it's funny you have a small gland become
what I'm ready for Todd the black one
yeah yeah you like yeah yeah you know I
believe in equality my cat's a princess
like a gay guy no okay female she's Wow
I would not want your cat Wow good
anyway yeah guys thanks for tuning into
the channel if you're new you can
subscribe up here you tubers and you
could check out Dan's gaming channel
that cyber channel and he just did a
coverage of each conference of III like
I did a video covering all the console
conferences now that I've seen more of
the trailers here I'm gonna be doing
hopefully a developer conference
breakdown I on the show nice yeah I like
to cover things with stuff I just
realize I got this wet spot right here
yeah yeah it's door which is though
myself earlier yeah you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine is
if we get enough followers dan can
finally get product placement and I
could get more product placement that's
not my goal that is your goal old ain't
about tending to the subs I doubt
someone I just wanna make videos for
people I just I just wanna make it puts
words in my mouth